This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When historians write the narrative of life in 2020, they're going to have a lot of ground to cover. One of the topics that might be easy to overlook is Doom's crawling. Another 4 million Americans filed for unemployment benefits. Florida recorded record high numbers of coronavirus cases today. Trump supporters clashed with Black Lives Matter protesters at the Washington Monument. Whether or not you've used the term,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当历史学家撰写2020年生活实录时，他们将有大量的素材需要涵盖。其中一个可能很容易被忽视的话题就是“末日滚动”。又有400万美国人申请了失业救济金。佛罗里达州今天记录的冠状病毒病例创下历史新高。特朗普支持者在华盛顿纪念碑与“黑命贵”抗议者发生冲突。不管你有没有用过这个词，
you've probably engaged in doomscrolling over the last few months. It's the uncontrollable urge to consume terrible story onto terrible story. So I'm flying for maybe the next pandemic week. This stream of bad news flows ceaselessly through our social media feeds at every hour of the day. You're the 7 million households in the United States. Overdoses are on the rise. Statue of Abolition is Frederick Tullus, the British has been disruptive and devastating in so many different ways. There are many terrible and difficult problems we face today,
在过去的几个月里，你大概也进行过末日滚动。这是一种无法控制的冲动，要去阅读一个又一个可怕的故事。所以我可能要在接下来的大流行周里乘飞机。这种源源不断的坏新闻在一天的每一个小时里都在我们的社交媒体信息流中无休止地流淌。你是美国的那700万户家庭。药物过量事件正在增加。废奴主义者雕像弗雷德里克·塔勒斯，英国的局势在这么多不同的方面一直具有破坏性和毁灭性。我们今天面临着许多可怕而困难的问题，
and they deserve our attention. But sometimes, we can get so consumed by what is going wrong that it can keep us from seeing what is going right. This is powerful implications. When we can see only one part of the world, we can't imagine our way to new possibilities and insights. If a country is at peace, if there is not a famine, there's no headline.
它们值得我们的关注。但有时，我们会过于沉迷于出错的事情，以至于看不到正在走上正轨的事情。这具有强大的含义。当我们只能看到世界的一部分时，我们就无法通过想象走向新的可能性和见解。如果一个国家处于和平状态，如果没有发生饥荒，就不会成为头条新闻。
But those are significant events if they apply to more and more regions of the world. And the only way to know that that's happening is by looking at data. This week on Hidden Brain, we continue our series exploring counterintuitive and provocative ideas about the state of the world in 2020. Today, why it's so hard to see things that are going well and how this oversight has profound consequences. Stephen Pinker is a psychologist at Harvard University. He argues that we tend to overlook the astonishing progress that humanity has made, particularly in our own lifetimes.
但如果这些情况适用于越来越多的世界地区，它们就是重大事件。而了解这一点正在发生的唯一方法就是通过查看数据。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们继续推出系列节目，探讨关于2020年世界状态的反直觉和挑衅性观点。今天，为什么很难看到进展顺利的事物，以及这种忽视会产生怎样的深远后果。史蒂芬·平克是哈佛大学的心理学家。他认为，我们往往忽视了人类所取得的惊人进步，特别是在我们有生之年。
He is the author of several books, including Enlightenment Now, the case for Reason, Science, Humanism and Progress. When I spoke to him recently, I began by asking whether the grim picture painted by many journalists, policy experts and politicians is an accurate view of the world. Well, it's a highly non-random sample of the worst things that have happened in an interval of time. And whenever you do that, since there are bad things
他是多本著作的作者，包括《当下的启蒙：为理性、科学、人道主义和进步辩护》。不久前我和他交谈时，我首先问他，许多记者、政策专家和政治家所描绘的这幅严峻图景是否是对世界的准确看法。嗯，这是在一段时间内发生的最好与最坏事情中高度非随机的样本。每当你这样做时，由于坏事
that happen somewhere on Earth on any day, it will give you a distorted picture if you interpret that sample as representative. But it rarely is, particularly in the news, the bad news captures our attention. And for that matter, any news, anything that unfolds quickly is more likely to be bad than good, because it's easy for something to go wrong very quickly.
在地球上的某个地方每天都在发生，如果你把这个样本解释为具有代表性，它就会给你一幅扭曲的图景。但它很少是这样的，特别是在新闻中，坏新闻吸引了我们的注意力。而且就此而言，任何新闻，任何快速展开的事情都更有可能是坏事而不是好事，因为事情很快出问题是很容易的。
For something to go right, it tends to creep up a few percentage points a year and perhaps compound, but there's rarely a Thursday in October in which something excellent happens. So when you say the picture is distorted, I don't think you mean to say that it's wrong at a factual level. There have been school shootings, there are economic setbacks, there is crime. Your point is not that these events didn't happen, but that our focus on them is somehow skewed. Precisely.
至于事情走向正确，它往往每年以几个百分点的速度缓慢爬升并可能复利，但在十月份的某个星期四，很少会发生什么极其优秀的事情。所以当你觉得这幅图景被扭曲时，我想你并不是说它在事实层面上是错的。确实发生过校园枪击案，有过经济挫折，也有犯罪。你的观点不是这些事件没有发生，而是我们对它们的关注在某种程度上有些偏颇。正是如此。
It is a report of all the worst things that happen on any given day. That's almost what the news is. Now, of course, it's vital that we know about bad things when they happen, but we have to take into account that that's what our news feed gives us, and it is not a representative picture of the world as a whole. A lot of things that go right consist of
这是对任何特定日子里发生的所有最糟糕事情的报道。新闻几乎就是这样的。当然，当坏事发生时我们了解它们至关重要，但我们必须考虑到这就是我们的新闻源给我们的东西，它并不是整个世界的一幅具有代表性的图景。许多进展顺利的事情包含着
nothing happening. If a country is at peace, if a city has not had a school shooting, if there is not a famine, there's no headline. But those are significant events if they apply to more and more regions of the world. And the only way to know that that's happening is by looking at data, at graphs that count the number of wars, the number of people who starve, the number of people who are poor, the number of people who are sick, as a proportion of the number of people on Earth or number of people in the country. And that's the way you can tell whether the world is changing. As long as bad things haven't gone to zero, which they never will, then
什么都没有发生。如果一个国家处于和平状态，如果一个城市没有发生校园枪击案，如果没有发生饥荒，就不会有头条新闻。但如果这些情况适用于越来越多的世界地区，它们就是重大事件。而了解这一情况正在发生的唯一方法就是查看数据，查看那些统计战争数量、忍饥挨饿人数、贫困人数、生病人数的图表，并将其作为地球上总人口或该国总人口的比例。这就是你判断世界是否在改变的方法。只要坏事没有归零，而它们永远不会归零，那么
the news will always present a biased sample of the state of the world. And you're absolutely right, not because they are dishonest or because it's fake news, it's real news, but it's just not a representative sample. So let's look at what that representative sample might look like, and let's look at three basic measures that you discuss in the book, health, wealth, and happiness. And let's start with health and longevity. Researchers have asked people to guess, and this is after taking into account debts from infant mortality and pandemics
新闻将永远呈现一幅对世界现状带有偏见的样本。你说得完全对，不是因为他们不诚实或因为这是假新闻，这是真新闻，但它确实不是一个具有代表性的样本。因此，让我们来看看这个具有代表性的样本可能是什么样的，让我们来看看你在书中讨论的三个基本指标：健康、财富和幸福。让我们从健康和长寿开始。研究人员让人们去猜，这是在考虑了婴儿死亡率、大流行病、
and hunger and war, what average life expectancy is around the world? What do people say when they're asked that question, Steve? When they try to imagine an average across the entire planet, including all of the poorest countries, they tend to make guesses in the 50s, mentally compensating for the elderly people in our society and their image of people dying young in other societies. The answer worldwide is more than 71, and the average for developed countries is in the low 80s. Now, this is not just about reducing infer mortality, although that's obviously a big part of it,
饥饿和战争造成的死亡之后，世界各地的平均预期寿命是多少？史蒂夫，当人们被问到这个问题时，他们是怎么说的？当他们试图想象整个地球的平均水平，包括所有最贫穷的国家时，他们的猜测往往在50岁左右，他们在精神上抵消了我们社会中的老年人，以及他们对其他社会中人们过早死亡的印象。世界范围内的答案是超过71岁，而发达国家的平均水平则在80岁出头。现在，这不仅关乎降低婴儿死亡率，尽管这显然是其中的很大一部分，
your odds of living longer are higher today than they were in the past at almost every age. Is that correct? Yes, because one could object that maybe all we're doing is we're rescuing neonates from infant mortality. Ascetic might say, well, we're not really living longer, we're just saving more babies, which is a good thing, but it's not the same as living longer. In reality, though, we are living longer.
今天你在几乎每个年龄段活得更久的几率都比过去更高。是这样吗？是的，因为有人可能会反驳说，也许我们所做的只是把新生儿从婴儿死亡率中拯救出来。一个苦行者可能会说，嗯，我们并不是真的活得更久了，我们只是拯救了更多的婴儿，这是一件好事，但这不等同于活得更久。然而在现实中，我们确实活得更长了。
That is, if you look at the, how many years you have left to live, if you've made it to 40, if you've made it to 50, if you've made it to 70, all of those have shown an increase. So yes, someone who is 70 today has more years of life ahead of them than someone who is 70, say, 50 years ago or 100 years ago. We're going to talk a little later in the conversation about differences between groups and nations and about the issue of inequality.
也就是说，如果你看看你还剩多少年要活，如果你活到了40岁，如果你活到了50岁，如果你活到了70岁，所有这些都显示出了增长。所以是的，今天70岁的人比比如50年前或100年前70岁的人，拥有更多余的生命。在接下来的对话中，我们将讨论群体和国家之间的差异以及不平等问题。
But is it true that the benefits of health and longevity are exclusive to rich countries and to rich people? Yes, just about everything that's good in life. There's more of in wealthy countries than in poor countries. But poor countries have seen huge increases in life expectancy. Above and beyond, there are increases in wealth. Even though gold-plated medical care can extend the life of a 75-year-old, but basic measures like sanitation, clean water, mosquito control can really stretch the lifespans in poor countries. And what about the question of wealth itself? How does global wealth compare with the past,
但是，健康和长寿的好处是否只属于富裕国家和富有的人，这属实吗？是的，生活中几乎所有美好的东西，富裕国家都比贫穷国家多。但贫穷国家的预期寿命也出现了巨大的增长。超出了财富的增长。即使是镀金的医疗护理可以延长一个75岁老人的寿命，但基本的措施，如环境卫生、清洁水、灭蚊，确实可以在贫穷国家大幅延长寿命。那么关于财富本身的问题呢？全球财富与过去相比如何，
and how does it compare in rich countries and poor countries? The world is vastly wealthier than it was. Gross world product is probably maybe 200 times what it was in the early 1700s, and extreme poverty, which might be our best measure because it measures the most human suffering, has shown a spectacular decline. 200 years ago, perhaps 90% of the world lived in extreme poverty by today's standards, doing as best we can, of course, to equate living conditions then and now.
在富裕国家和贫穷国家又如何比较呢？世界比过去要富裕得多。世界生产总值可能是1700年代初期的200倍左右，而极端贫困——这可能是我们最好的衡量标准，因为它衡量了最多的人类痛苦——已经出现了惊人的下降。200年前，按照今天的标准，大约90%的世界人口生活在极端贫困中，当然，我们尽最大努力使当时和现在的生活条件对等。
Now it's less than 9%. And in fact, in the last 30 years, there's been a 75% reduction in the proportion of people in the world who live in extreme poverty. So this is a massive accomplishment of our species. And one that very few people are aware of. So when we look at this contrast between the past, as you point out, there have been really dramatic differences
现在这一比例不到9%。事实上，在过去30年中，世界生活在极端贫困中的人口比例下降了75%。所以这是我们物种的一项巨大成就。而且很少有人意识到这一点。因此，当我们看待过去与现在之间的这种对比时，正如你所指出的，在健康、财富和长寿方面确实存在巨大的差异，
in health, and in wealth, and in longevity, what explains the fact that if I was to read the New York Times front page for the last 100 years, the picture that I would draw from reading the front page of the New York Times is not a picture of progress or achievement or change, but it would be a picture that says bad things have happened. Today is probably worse than yesterday. Bad things are going to happen in the future as well.
那么该如何解释这样一个事实：如果我去读过去100年的《纽约时报》头版，我从阅读《纽约时报》头版中得出的图景不是一幅关于进步、成就或改变的图景，而是一幅显示坏事发生了的图景。今天可能比昨天更糟。未来也会有坏事发生。
It is an irony, and of course we're not picking on the New York Times. It's just the most famous newspaper and the one that data scientists have analyzed in the greatest depth. But it is true that the emotional tone of stories in the New York Times, and for that matter, press outlets worldwide, has declined over the last 75 years, just as measures of human well-being, like peace and nutrition and health and longevity, have improved. So what explains the decline? Part of it is that the journalism has become more efficient and conscientious at reporting events
这是一个讽刺，当然我们并不是在挑《纽约时报》的毛病。它只是最著名的报纸，也是数据科学家进行最深入分析的报纸。但事实是，过去75年来，《纽约时报》以及全球新闻媒体中故事的情感基调有所下降，而人类福祉的指标，如和平、营养、健康和长寿，却有所改善。那么，如何解释这种下降呢？部分原因是新闻业在报道
on the other side of the world, so that if there was hunger in Africa in the 1950s, I don't think a whole lot of people really cared. It's a good thing that our circle of sympathy is expanded so that we do consider a human catastrophe elsewhere in the world as worthy of our concern. There's also a change in attitude and mindset. In the early 60s, there was a peak in trusted institutions, in governments, in churches, in science, in the press,
世界另一端的事情时变得更加高效和认真，因此如果在20世纪50年代非洲发生饥荒，我不认为会有很多人真正关心。我们的同情圈扩大了，以至于我们认为世界其他地方的人类灾难值得我们关注，这是一件好事。态度和心态也发生了变化。在60年代初，对机构、政府、教会、科学、新闻界、
in international organizations. And people, I think, joined in a sense of collective accomplishment of having improved the world. Since the early 1960s, trust in every institution has fallen. And people assume the stance of social critics and are eager to point to crises, catastrophes, failures, corruption, and so on. And the stance of a sophisticated person is to cry what isn't working, rather than to celebrate what is working. Psychologists talk about something called the availability bias.
国际组织的信任达到了顶峰。而且我认为，人们沉浸在改善了世界的集体成就感中。自20世纪60年代初以来，对各个机构的信任都在下降。人们采取了社会批评家的姿态，渴望指出危机、灾难、失败、腐败等等。而一个成熟之人的姿态是哭诉哪里出了问题，而不是赞美哪里运作良好。心理学家谈到了一种叫做“可得性偏见”的现象。
What is this bias and how is it germane to our conversation about the new Steve? What we do is we troll memory for examples and the more quickly examples come to mind that is the more available they are to memory, the more frequent we judge an event to be. So if we've just read about a shark attack, then we don't go into the water. If there's been a hijacking, we stay at a plane, even those statistically car travel is much more dangerous. We take foolish risks like using our smartphone while driving because there's rarely a headline reporting a gory crash that kills hundreds of people
什么是这种偏见，它与我们关于史蒂夫的新闻的对话有什么关系？我们所做的是在记忆中搜寻例子，例子在脑海中浮现得越快，也就是说它们在记忆中越容易获得，我们就会判断某个事件发生的频率越高。因此，如果我们刚刚读到关于鲨鱼袭击的新闻，我们就不会下水。如果发生了一起劫机事件，我们就会呆在飞机上，尽管从统计学上讲，汽车出行要危险得多。我们会冒一些愚蠢的风险，比如在开车时使用智能手机，因为很少有头条新闻报道数百人丧生的血腥车祸，
because some idiot drives well texting. So our sense of danger and risk is driven by the images, the anecdotes. That's exactly what, of course, the news feeds us. And so, in many cases, our sense of danger is out of whack with the reality. So it's striking, of course, that so much of your book is about numbers and statistics, because this is, of course, how you can compare the present and the past. But I wonder if this is one of the reasons we fail to see how far we've come. You know, when we look at the challenges we see in the present,
原因是一些白痴在发短信时开车。因此，我们对危险和风险的感知是由这些图像和轶事驱动的。当然，这正是新闻供给我们的东西。因此，在许多情况下，我们的危险感与现实脱节。因此，引人注目的是，你的书中很大一部分是关于数字和统计数据的，因为这当然是你比较现在和过去的方式。但我想知道，这是否是我们未能看到我们已经走了多远的原因之一。你知道，当我们审视眼前面临的挑战时，
school shootings or pandemics or recessions, we hear those stories through the eyes of living, breathing people. We see the faces of people, we hear those stories through the eyes of living, breathing people. We see the faces of people, we hear their names, and these are people who we feel a connection with. They are emotionally compelling. When you make a case of how the present is much better than the past, you're making that case with statistics, and statistics, sadly, are just not as emotionally compelling as people.
校园枪击案、大流行病或经济衰退，我们透过有血有肉的人的眼睛听到这些故事。我们看到人们的面孔，我们透过有血有肉的人的眼睛听到这些故事。我们看到人们的面孔，我们听到他们的名字，这些人让我们感到与他们有联系。它们在情感上令人信服。当你论证现在比过去好得多时，你是用统计数据来论证的，而悲哀的是，统计数据在情感上不如人本身那样引人注目。
That is true. They ought to be. Statistics have the great moral value of treating every life as equally valuable. That is, it's not just the people who live in the next block, it's not just people who look like you or speak your language, but all human lives are treated equally. It takes into account all of the happy fulfilled lives that we never hear about precisely because nothing goes wrong.
确实如此。本该如此的。统计数据具有巨大的道德价值，即把每一个生命视作同等珍贵。也就是说，不仅仅是住在你隔壁街区的人，不仅仅是那些长得像你或说你语言的人，而是所有人类的生命都被同等对待。它考虑到了所有那些我们从未听说过的幸福充实的生活，这恰恰是因为没有出任何差错。
The people who bring up their kids, the kids get an education, they have children in their turn. They're not poor and there are a lot of those. And since that's what we want people to achieve, we should know how many of them there are so we can ensure that they're more of them. Paradoxically, the way our attention and empathy are captured by human stories makes us vulnerable to bad actors who can game the system. That's
人们养育孩子，孩子们接受教育，他们接着也有了自己的孩子。他们并不贫穷，而且这样的人有很多。既然这是我们希望人们达到的目标，我们就应该知道有多少这样的人，以便我们能够确保有更多这样的人。矛盾的是，我们的注意力和同情心被人类的故事所吸引，这使我们容易受到操纵系统的坏蛋的攻击。那就是
what school shootings consist of. These are people who are desperate for fame or notoriety. There are nobody's who want to become somebody's. They know that they can do it. That a guaranteed root to fame is to kill a lot of innocent people in a short period of time, especially people who we can imagine being ourselves. It's also the trick behind terrorism, which kills very few people, but terrorists, too,
校园枪击案的构成。这些人极度渴望名声或声名狼藉。他们是无名小卒，想成为大人物。他们知道自己能做到。通往名誉的保证途径就是在短时间内杀死大量无辜的人，特别是那些我们可以想象成我们自己的人。这也是恐怖主义背后的伎俩，它杀害的人很少，但恐怖分子也
know how to game the press by calling attention to their cause by killing a relatively small number of innocent people, but doing so in a public place where we can easily imagine ourselves or our loved ones. So paradoxically, the fact that our emotions are captured by, by familiar faces, by people like us, by people we can imagine knowing, leaves us open to manipulation. Steve points out that when good things happen, they tend to unfold slowly. When bad things happen, they tend to occur suddenly. The news focuses on sudden change, not things that happen routinely, even if those routine changes are a very
知道如何通过杀死相对少数无辜的人来将媒体的注意力吸引到他们的事业上，而且是在一个我们可以轻易想象自己或我们所爱之人的公共场所这样做。因此，矛盾的是，我们的情绪被熟悉的面孔、像我们这样的人、我们能想象认识的人所吸引，这让我们容易受到操纵。史蒂夫指出，当好事发生时，它们往往缓缓展开。当坏事发生时，它们往往突然降临。新闻关注突如其来的变化，而不是那些例行发生的事情，即使那些例行变化是一件
big deal. When 137,000 people are pulled out of extreme poverty on a daily basis, as this happened on average every day for the last 25 years. It isn't news. Now as you listen to that statistic, you might be saying, hang on. What about the people still in poverty? What about the kids dying in school shootings? What about the gap in infant mortality between black people and white people in the United States?
非常大的事。当每天有13,7000人摆脱极端贫困时——就像过去25年中平均每天都在发生的那样。这不是新闻。现在，当你听到这个统计数据时，你可能会说，等等。那些仍然生活在贫困中的人呢？那些在校园枪击案中死去的孩子呢？美国黑人和白人之间婴儿死亡率的差距呢？
Steve's point is not that you are wrong to be skeptical of claims of progress, but that knee-jerk skepticism has now become so automatic for lots of us that we don't even stop to realize that we are doing it. Another psychological bias at play has to do with our view of the past. We don't realize how much better things are today, because we don't realize how bad things were in the past. Why? The accounts we have of the past mostly reflect the worldviews and perceptions of the most privileged members of those societies. When we compare our present with the past, we have a skewed sample that makes the past seem more pleasant than it was for most people.
史蒂夫的观点并不是说你对进步的宣称抱有怀疑是错误的，而是说这种本能的怀疑对我们许多人来说已经变得如此自动化，以至于我们甚至没有停下来意识到我们正在这样做。另一个发挥作用的心理偏见与我们对过去的看法有关。我们没有意识到今天的事情变得有多好，因为我们没有意识到过去的事情有多糟。为什么？我们关于过去的记录主要反映了那些社会中最特权成员的世界观和看法。当我们把现在与过去进行对比时，我们得到了一个有偏见的样本，使得过去对大多数人来说比实际情况更愉快。
Imagine if people from the future could only hear stories of today that were written by the 1%. Even if their lives were much better than most people today, they might say, clearly not very much has changed. It said that history is written by the victors, but history is also written by those with money and leisure and literacy. Now more and more people today do have money and leisure and literacy, but in the past, those were perquisites of a very small elite, and the lifestyles of the rich and famous several hundred years ago were apt to mistake for the lifestyles of people in general. When we come back, our failure to see how much things have changed from the past is only one aspect of our blindness.
想象一下，如果来自未来的人只能听到由1%的人撰写的关于今天的的故事。即使他们的生活比今天的大多数人要好得多，他们也可能会说，显然没有发生多大的改变。俗话说历史是由胜利者书写的，但历史也是由那些有钱、有闲、有文化的人书写的。现在越来越多的人确实有了金钱、闲暇和文化，但在过去，那些是非常小的一群精英的特权，几百年前富人和名人的生活方式很容易被误认为是普通人的生活方式。当我们回来时，我们未能看到事情从过去发生了多大变化，只是我们盲目性的一个方面。
We also fail to see how much things can change in the future. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the first century BC, a volcano erupted with terrible force. The explosion was so massive, it affected the ebb and flow of the Nile River. Causing catastrophic failures of the life-giving Nile flood and years of famine. Thousands of people died. Sinclair, Patra, and her son.
我们也未能看到未来事情会有多大变化。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。公元前一世纪，一座火山以可怕的力量爆发了。爆炸规模如此巨大，以至于影响了尼罗河的涨落。导致赋予生命的尼罗河泛滥灾难性失败和多年的饥荒。成千上万的人死去了。辛克莱，帕特拉和她的儿子。
Centuries later, a crop failure in Ireland led to what is now known as the Irish potato famine. There had been potato failures before Asian 45 crop failures, but mostly there were for one year. What made the famine unique really was the fact that the potato field again and again and again, so it was the long evidentity of them.
几个世纪后，爱尔兰的农作物歉收导致了现在被称为爱尔兰土豆大饥荒的事件。在此之前也曾发生过土豆歉收，亚洲45年也有农作物歉收，但大多只持续一年。真正使这次饥荒独一无二的是土豆田一次又一次、接连不断地歉收，因此它是长期的显现。
In the mid-20th century, famines, some caused by human forces, others not, led to millions of deaths around the globe. For as long as humans have been on the planet, starvation has been with us. It was so common that for many centuries, societies believed it was inevitable. Imagining a world that could feed itself felt hopeless. And then in the early 1940s, an Iowa farm boy took the first step to what conquering
在20世纪中期，由人类力量或其他原因引起的饥荒导致全球数百万人死亡。自从人类在地球上存在以来，饥饿就一直伴随着我们。它是如此普遍，以至于许多世纪以来，社会都认为这是不可避免的。想象一个能够自给自足的世界感觉毫无希望。然后在20世纪40年代初，一个爱荷华州的农场男孩迈出了征服
World Hunger. His name was Norman Borlog. For people who work in agriculture, Norman Barlog is a rock star. He even has his own rap performed by the 11-year-old son of a plant scientist. The research that would make him famous began in 1944. He was invited to go to Mexico to figure out what to do about the country's failing wheat crops. The wheat was shriveling in the dry, depleted soil, producing tiny amounts of grain and dying from disease.
世界饥饿的第一步。他的名字叫诺曼·博洛格。对于从事农业工作的人来说，诺曼·巴洛格是个大明星。他甚至有自己的说唱歌曲，由一位植物科学家的11岁儿子表演。使他成名研究始于1944年。他应邀前往墨西哥，找出如何应对该国不断减产的小麦作物。小麦在干燥、贫瘠的土壤中枯萎，产出极少量的谷物并死于疾病。
The Mexican people were not getting enough to eat. I don't know what we can do to help these people, he wrote to his wife, but we've got to do something. Norman Barlog was an accomplished plant geneticist with the instincts of a farmer, and so he knew what was wrong with the wheat in Mexico. It was the same thing that challenged farmers everywhere. Basically, nature did not design food crops for our benefit. Psychologist Steven Pinker.
墨西哥人民没有得到足够的食物。他给妻子写信道：“我不知道我们能做些什么来帮助这些人，但我们必须做点什么。”诺曼·巴洛格是一位成就斐然的植物遗传学家，有着农民的直觉，因此他知道墨西哥的小麦出了什么问题。这与各地农民所面临的挑战是同一回事。基本上，大自然设计粮食作物并不是为了我们的利益。心理学家史蒂芬·平克。
Natural selection favors organisms, including plants that reproduce, and feeding us just isn't their problem. So, Borlough took evolution into his own hands by selective breeding. In the early days, Borlok did the work himself. Hunched over in the hot Mexican sun, he used delicate tweezers to pluck tiny, pollen-producing stamens off of wheat blossoms. He wanted to keep them from reproducing. Then, he fertilized the wheat blossoms with the pollen of a new variety.
自然选择偏爱能够繁殖的生物，包括植物，而养活我们根本不是它们的问题。因此，博洛格通过人工选择育种将进化掌握在了自己手中。在早期，博洛格自己完成这项工作。他驼着背在炎热的墨西哥阳光下，用精致的镊子从小麦花上拔下微小的、产生花粉的雄蕊。他想阻止它们繁殖。然后，他用新品种的花粉给小麦花授精。
It produced a novel combination. Of the thousands of strains of wheat he crossed over the next 10 years, only a few resulted in anything usable. Eventually, he found something that worked, a blend of a high yield strain of wheat, and a shorter, harder variety from Japan that was known as a dwarf plant. It was a mishmash that nature would never have created on its own. If you've got a kind of a Deus Examac, you know, a god whose directing evolution,
它产生了一种新奇的组合。在他接下来10年杂交的数千个小麦品系中，只有少数取得了任何可用的结果。最终，他找到了管用的东西，一种高产小麦品种与一种被称为矮生植物的来自日本的更矮、更硬品种的混合物。这是大自然绝对不会凭空创造的大杂烩。如果你有一个类似于机械降神的东西，你知道的，一个指导进化的神，
in this case the god being in Borlaug, he could select for the plants that had dwarf stocks, and higher yields and needed less water and could be harvested twice during a season. Now of course, we have techniques to do this today that would probably expedite the process to a matter of potentially months or even weeks, but Borlaug didn't, and he describes the work
在这个例子中神就是博洛格，他可以选择那些具有矮秆、更高产量、需要更少水并且可以在一个季节收获两次的植物。当然，现在我们有了可以做到这一点的技术，可能会把这个过程加快到可能只需几个月甚至几周的时间，但博洛格当时没有，他将这项工作描述为
as mind-warpingly tedious. Do you have a sense of how difficult it was for him working in Mexico? You grow a lot of wheat. You look over the hundreds of plants in hopes that one mutant will have the same yield in grain, but be shorter or let need less water or mature earlier. You harvest the seeds, you plant those seeds, hoping that one of those mutations will be still more beneficial from the point of view of the farmer,
令人头脑发麻的枯燥乏味。你对他在墨西哥工作时有多困难有什么概念吗？你种植大量的小麦。你查看数百株植物，希望有一个突变体能在谷物产量上相同，但更矮、或者需要更少水、或者成熟得更早。你收获种子，你种植这些种子，希望这些突变中的一个对农民来说仍然更有利，
repeat generation after generation after generation. Wow. So these discoveries eventually led to what is sometimes called the green revolution and accounts vary in terms of what the impact of the Green Revolution was. But some people think that through his discoveries, Norman Borlaug may have saved a billion lives. Now, it's possible that this is an exaggeration, but there's no question the number was at least in the tens of millions. And that is simply an unfathomably large number. It truly is.
一代又一代、一代又一代地重复。哇。因此，这些 discoveries 最终导致了有时被称为绿色革命的东西，对于绿色革命的影响各方说法不一。但有些人认为，通过他的发现，诺曼·博洛格可能拯救了十亿人的生命。现在，这可能是夸张，但毫无疑问，这个数字至少在几千万。这是一个令人不可思议的巨大数字。确实如此。
He did win the Nobel Peace Prize in, I believe, 1970 for this discovery. He didn't end a war. and a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than a more than without turning the entire planet into agricultural land. In other words, we've become much more efficient in how we are using farmland compared to 200 years ago. Indeed. And something that is not sufficiently appreciated within the environmental movement is how beneficial it is for nature if we make human activities denser. That is, if we grow more food on less land, that's more land that can return to natural state to forests. And of course that has been happening in North America
他确实因这一发现在1970年获得了诺贝尔和平奖。他没有结束一场战争。无需将整个星球变成农田。换句话说，与200年前相比，我们在使用农田方面变得更加高效。确实如此。环保运动中没有得到充分认识的一点是，如果我们使人类活动更集中，这对自然有多大益处。也就是说，如果我们用更少的土地种植更多的食物，那么就有更多的土地可以恢复到自然状态变成森林。当然，这已经在北美
and Europe where abandoned farmland is being reclaimed by forests. More importantly, it could lead to less forests being cut down in the first place. That is starting to happen in tropical regions, but not nearly as quickly as it should. The peak of deep forestation has passed, but there's still an alarming amount of deforestation. There'd be much less if we didn't need that land to graze cattle and grow crops. With the abundance has come affordability, as you say in the US in 1901, and ours wages could buy three quarts of milk, a century later the same wages could buy 16 quarts. So food has become much more affordable to many more people because of these discoveries. Indeed.
和欧洲发生，那里废弃的农田正在被森林收复。更重要的是，它可以从一开始就减少被砍伐的森林。这开始在热带地区发生，但速度远远不够快。深层森林砍伐的顶峰已经过去，但仍然存在令人担忧的森林砍伐量。如果我们不需要这些土地来放牧牛群和种植农作物， deforestation 将会少得多。伴随着丰裕而来的是负担能力，正如你在美国所说，在1901年，按小时计算的工资可以买三夸脱牛奶，一个世纪后同样的工资可以买16夸脱。因此，由于这些发现，许多人更能买得起食物了。确实如此。
And there are things that we forget, like the campaign slogan of chicken in every pot. Fortunately, at least in developed countries, poor people can afford chicken and they can afford eggs, most anyway, not all, tragically, but more and more. The Depression era song, One Meatball, it told the story of a person who was begging a restaurant to give one meatball together with his bread. We could afford but one meatball. Now of course we have the opposite problem, obesity. Now obesity is a terrible problem.
有些事情我们已经忘记了，比如“家家有鸡吃”的竞选口号。幸运的是，至少在发达国家，穷人吃得起鸡肉，也吃得起鸡蛋，无论如何大部分人是这样的，并非所有人，不幸的是，但越来越多的人能吃得起。大萧条时期的歌曲《一个肉丸》讲述了一个人乞求餐馆给他一个肉丸配面包的故事。我们只买得起一个肉丸。现在当然我们有了相反的问题，肥胖。现在肥胖是一个严重的问题。
It is dragging down the increase in longevity that we would otherwise enjoy. But of the faced with a choice between two problems, starvation or obesity, obesity is a better problem to have. Still a tough one. You mentioned a thought experiment that was offered by the former president Barack Obama. If you remember that experiment, tell us what he thought experiment wise and what would we draw from it. Obama said, if you had to pick a moment to be born and you didn't know who you would be
它正在拖累我们本可以享有的寿命延长。但在面对两个问题——饥饿还是肥胖——的选择时，肥胖是一个更好的问题。依然是个棘手的问题。你提到了前总统巴拉克·奥巴马提出的一个思想实验。如果你还记得那个实验，告诉我们他的思想实验是什么样的，我们能从中得出什么结论。奥巴马说，如果你必须选择一个出生的时刻，而你不知道你会是谁
or where you would be, you would pick now. That is, you didn't know whether you'd be black or white, male or female, African or European, then your odds of living a long, healthy and fulfilling life would be greatest now. Obama was wisely asking us to assess how far we've come. So it's interesting, I mean, if interesting is the word I'm looking for, that millions of people may have directly benefited from Norman Borlaug and his discoveries. And of course, their descendants, who also probably are many millions of people.
或者你会在哪里，你会选择现在。也就是说，你不知道你会是黑人还是白人，男性或女性，非洲人还是欧洲人，那么你过上长寿、健康和充实生活的几率在现在是最大的。奥巴马明智地要求我们评估我们已经取得了多大进步。所以很有趣，我的意思是，如果“有趣”正是我所寻找的词，数百万人可能直接受益于诺曼·博洛格和他的发现。当然，还有他们的后代，可能也是数以百万计的人。
But of all these people, very few have probably even heard of his name, let alone think that they owe their lives to him. So it's an interesting irony, isn't it, that you have these people who have these discoveries that impact so many people, but far from being household names, they've almost been forgotten. Indeed. And there's a genre that was popular when I was a child, the heroic biography of the scientist or inventor, that I don't know if it's fallen by the wayside.
但在所有这些人中，极少有人甚至听说过他的名字，更不用说认为他们欠他一条命了。所以这是一个有趣的讽刺，不是吗？你有这些对这么多人产生影响的发现的创造者，但远非家喻户晓，他们几乎已经被遗忘了。确实如此。有一种流派在我小时候很受欢迎，即科学家或发明家的英雄传记，我不知道它是否已经被时代淘汰了。
I don't have a child of the right age, but the sanctification of people like Louis Pasteur or Banting who discovered insulin, Jenner who discovered vaccination. There was an appreciation that these were true heroes. Virginia Apgarh who devised the scale of infant well-being that allows pediatricians to identify infants at risk, a group through to a lion who pioneered rational drug design. There are people who, unlike many of our political heroes, deserve credit for saving tens hundreds of millions of lives, but they are unknown, or at least unknown to outside a circle of historians of science. I'm wondering again if this is part of how our minds work. Is it possible our evolutionary history has taught us to think of generosity and compassion as acts of direct interpersonal
我没有合适年龄的孩子，但对路易·巴斯德或发现胰岛素的班廷、发现疫苗的詹纳的顶礼膜拜。人们曾意识到这些是真正的英雄。设计了婴儿健康量表使儿科医生能够识别高危婴儿的弗吉尼亚·阿普加，开创了理性药物设计的群体。有一些人，不像我们的许多政治英雄，他们因拯救了数千万甚至数亿人的生命而理应受到赞誉，但他们默默无闻，或者至少在科学史学家圈子之外默默无闻。我再次想知道这是否是我们大脑运作方式的一部分。我们的进化历史是否有可能教会了我们把慷慨和同情心视为直接的人际
helplessness? We don't think about a faceless scientist who's working in some far away lab as the pinnacle of compassion, even if that person ends up saving many millions of lives. There is some of that that we do have a hero narrative as someone who defeats evil and evil enemy. That's who we tend to lie in eyes and canonize. Although there are also historical and cultural changes. 1955, a year of anxiety and triumphs. For example in the 1950s when polio struck tarant of the hearts of every parent, we're afraid that their their
无助的行为？我们不会认为一个在某个遥远实验室里工作的无名科学家是同情心的巅峰，即使这个人最终拯救了数百万人的生命。确实有这样一部分原因，我们有一个英雄叙事，即一个战胜邪恶和邪恶敌人的英雄。这才是我们倾向于浪漫化和奉为偶像的人。尽管也有历史和文化的变迁。1955年，充满焦虑与胜利的一年。例如在20世纪50年代，当小儿麻痹症袭击了每位父母的心灵时，人们担心他们
child might be paralyzed if they go out and and swim in a public pool in a hot summer day. Leading drug firms shifted into high gear to meet a national demand, which spread to every crossroads despite early controversy. When Jonas Salk discovered an ounce that his polio vaccine was safe and effective, he did become a national hero. He was offered a ticker tape parade through Manhattan, church bells and factory whistles sounded. People took the day off, strangers hugged each other. He really was universally beloved.
的孩子如果在炎热的夏日外出并在公共游泳池里游泳可能会瘫痪。各大制药公司全力以赴以满足全国的需求，尽管早期存在争议，但这种需求蔓延到了每一个十字路口。当乔纳斯·索尔克宣布他的小儿麻痹症疫苗安全有效时，他确实成为了民族英雄。曼哈顿为他举行了盛大的纸带游行，教堂钟声和工厂汽笛齐鸣。人们放假一天，陌生人互相拥抱。他确实受到了普遍的喜爱。
It's less likely to happen now. I mean, we do it with athletes. We do it with politicians within our own faction, with Hollywood celebrities and musical stars, not so much with scientists and medical pioneers. Do you think that might change with the ongoing COVID-19 pandemic? I mean, I'm thinking about all the scenes we've seen from around the world of people cheering for doctors and healthcare workers. And now admittedly, it's not necessarily cheering for scientists per se, but it's basically acknowledging something that, you know, we should have acknowledged all along, which is that there are people who
现在这种情况不太可能发生了。我的意思是，我们对运动员这样做。我们对我们自己派系的政治家、好莱坞名人和音乐明星这样做，但对科学家和医学先驱却不那么热衷。你认为这可能会随着正在进行的COVID-19大流行而改变吗？我的意思是，我想到了我们从世界各地看到的那些人们为医生和医护人员欢呼的场景。现在必须承认，这不一定是在为科学家本身欢呼，但它基本上是对一件事情的承认，你知道的，我们本该一直承认的，那就是有人
are saving our lives, but not doing it in a very public fashion. They're working, they're working behind the scenes, largely. Indeed, and I think if it so happened that one lone genius came up with a vaccine or an antiviral, it may well be that she or he would be a secular saint. Anthony Fauci almost approached that role until because of our rampant politicization and polarization, he became something of a villain to certain factions of the political right. Although I think he still enjoys tremendous popularity
在拯救我们的生命，但他们并没有以非常公开的方式这样做。他们主要是在幕后工作。确实如此，而且我认为，如果恰好有一个孤单的天才想出了疫苗或抗病毒药物，他或她很可能会成为世俗圣徒。安东尼·福奇几乎接近了这个角色，直到由于我们猖獗的政治化和极化，他成了政治右翼某些派系的某种恶棍。尽管我认为他依然享有极高的人气
and nationwide. The problem, of course, is that it's less and less common that scientific discoveries are made by alone genius. Nowadays, and even in the past, but especially nowadays, they tend to be accomplished by teams of collaborators, by people standing on the shoulders of giants who came before them. Even in the best of times, the pastor or the banding was an exception and probably does not exist today.
并且在全国范围内。当然，问题在于，科学发现越来越少是由孤单的天才做出来的。如今，甚至在过去也是如此，但尤其是现在，它们往往是由合作团队完成的，由站在前人肩膀上的人完成的。即使在最好的时期，巴斯德或班廷也是个例外，今天可能已经不存在了。
Now, of course, we know from the scientific literature that often a paper will have 100 authors and that's just one paper. Stephen Pinker's arguments can be particularly hard to embrace in 2020 when the world feels like it's on fire for lots of different reasons. To some people, his claims may feel out of touch at best and like gaslighting at worst. When we come back, we get his response to those criticisms and look at why people on both the political left and the right have found fault with his worldview. Psychologist Steve Pinker argues that we tend to focus on what is wrong with the world
现在，当然，我们从科学文献中知道，一篇论文往往有一百个作者，而这仅仅是一篇论文。在2020年，当世界因为各种原因感觉仿佛陷入火海时，史蒂芬·平克的观点可能尤其难以让人接受。对某些人来说，他的主张充其量让人觉得与现实脱节，最坏情况下则像是精神控制。当我们回来时，我们将听到他对这些批评的回应，并探讨为什么政治左右两派的人都会发现他的世界观存在问题。心理学家史蒂芬·平克认为，我们往往专注于世界哪里出了问题
while paying little attention to the way things have been transformed for the better. Our blindness runs in two directions. We fail to see the contrast between the present and the past, and we fail to see how much the present can be transformed in the future. Steve, if I'm a poor person in a rural area of the United States. If my kids have bad schools, if my home has contaminated running water, if the economy in my area is shot, I think it's small comfort for me to know that things were worse for people a century ago. So someone that might listen to your account might say, your optimism sounds clueless or
同时却很少关注事物是如何向更好的方向转变的。我们的盲目性体现在两个方向。我们看不到现在与过去的对比，也看不到现在在未来可以发生多大的改变。史蒂夫，如果我是美国农村地区的一个穷人，如果我的孩子们的学校很烂，如果我家的自来水收到了污染，如果我所在地区的经济一塌糊涂，我认为，得知一个世纪前的人们过得更糟，对我来说并没有多少安慰。所以，听了你的说法后，有人可能会说，你的乐观听起来不知轻重，或者
even worse, that it sounds cruel. How would you respond to this? It's a circular argument saying, let's look at the people who are worst off and, oh my goodness, they are not very well off. Well, yes, that's why you ask them. So until we achieve a utopia, which we never will, there always will be suffering. We ought to minimize it.
更糟糕的是，听起来很残忍。你对此有何回应？这是一种循环论证，意思是，让我们看看那些处境最糟的人，天哪，他们过得并不好。嗯，是的，这就是为什么你要去关注他们。因此，在我们实现乌托邦（而我们永远无法实现）之前，苦难将永远存在。我们应该将其降到最低。
We ought to strive for the least amount of human suffering worldwide. But to focus on the remaining suffering and ignoring the reduction in suffering is doing no favor to the people who still are suffering because it can lull us into fatalism. The poor will always be with you. It's fate, it's God's way, it's the natural state of affairs, whereas if you know that poverty and hunger and illiteracy and war are not necessary parts of the human condition, they can be reduced. That emboldens you to reduce them further, to drive the numbers down as low as possible. And imagine some cure for some horrible disease. You know, let's say that
我们应该努力在全球范围内最大限度地减少人类的痛苦。但是，如果只关注剩下的痛苦，而忽视痛苦的减少，对那些仍在受苦的人来说没有任何好处，因为这会让我们陷入宿命论。穷人将永远和你们在一起。这是命运，是上帝的旨意，是事物的自然状态；然而，如果你知道贫困、饥饿、文盲和战争并不是人类生存状况中不可避免的部分，它们是可以减少的。这会给你带来勇气，去进一步减少它们，把数字降到尽可能低的水平。想象一下某种可怕疾病的治愈方法。比如说，
a terrible killer like pancreatic cancer was subject to a cure that saved 99% of the people diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. If you were to say, well, yes, but for that one person who still has the fatal disease, it's not much comfort. Well, that's true, but it's, on the other hand, you pick that person because they are the rare exception. And if you ignore the 99 out of 100 whose lives have been saved, then you're not gonna be well equipped to save the remaining one or to encourage the kinds of activity that have driven suffering so much lower.
像胰腺癌这种可怕的杀手，如果有一种疗法能拯救 99% 的胰腺癌确诊患者。如果你说，嗯，是的，但对于那个仍然患有绝症的人来说，这并没有多少安慰。嗯，这确实如此，但另一方面，你挑出这个人是因为他们是罕见的例外。如果你忽视了 100 人中被拯救了生命的 99 人，那么你就没有能力去拯救剩下那个人，或者去鼓励那种让苦难大幅减少的活动。
that have driven suffering so much lower. You're talking the book about the difference between progress and utopia and the idea that progress often produces new problems of its own but those problems now have to be solved. It's sort of a never-ending cycle. But spend a moment just talking about this contrast between the idea of progress and the idea of utopia and how in some ways it colors the way we think about our lives. One of the surprises that I have encountered in simply digging for data on how life has changed is that when there is an improvement, people have trouble wrapping their minds around it. They imagine that if there's improvement, that means there must be perfection,
让苦难大幅减少。你在书中谈到了进步与乌托邦之间的区别，以及这样一个观点：进步往往会带来其自身的新问题，但这些问题现在必须得到解决。这有点像一个永无止境的循环。但请花一点时间谈谈进步的概念与乌托邦的概念之间的这种对比，以及它在某种程度上是如何影响我们对生活的看法的。我在寻找关于生活如何改变的数据时遇到的惊喜之一是，当出现改善时，人们很难在大脑中理解它。他们想象，如果有改善，那就意味着必定存在完美，
and if there's still violence, if there's still poverty, that means nothing has changed. It may be a symptom of a tendency of the mind to conceive of things in black and white, rather than in shades of gray, and of course most of us live in the gray zones. So if we were neither fantastically rich in the past or grindingly poor in the present, we're among those whose lives have improved. So it really is important to think in numbers, in statistics, and shades of gray. To the extent that progress has taken place,
如果仍然存在暴力，如果仍然存在贫困，那就意味着一切都没有改变。这可能是人类思维倾向于用非黑即白而非灰度来看待事物的一种表现，当然，我们大多数人都生活在灰色地带。因此，如果我们既不是过去那种富得流油的人，也不是现在穷困潦倒的人，我们就是那些生活已经得到改善的人。所以，用数字、统计数据和灰度来思考真的很重要。从进步发生的程度来看，
it is only because we have deployed human ingenuity with the goal of making our lives better. To the extent that we do that, we can every once in a while succeed. If we keep the tricks that have worked and if we vowed never to try again the things that fail, then we can eke out progress a bit at a time. And that's how progress happens. It's the only way that progress happens. And it's not guaranteed to happen. Our natural state is ignorance, and the universe doesn't go
这仅仅是因为我们发挥了人类的智慧，其目的是让我们的生活变得更好。如果我们这样做了，我们就能时不时地取得成功。如果我们保留那些奏效的方法，如果我们发誓再也不尝试那些失败的事情，那么我们就能一点一点地取得进步。进步就是这样发生的。这是进步发生的唯一方式。而且这并不能保证一定会发生。我们的自然状态是无知，宇宙也不会
out of its way to explain itself to us. As we've mentioned before, solutions themselves create new problems which have to be solved in their turn. It doesn't mean that we simply substitute one problem for another. Obesity really is a better problem to have than mass starvation in famine. But it does mean that our work is never done. Likewise, the green revolution did have side effects in terms of pollutants from runoff, from synthetic fertilizers, displacement of traditional modes of agriculture. But still, given that a billion lives were saved, those are prices
特意向我们解释它自己。正如我们之前提到的，解决方案本身会产生新的问题，这些问题反过来又必须得到解决。这并不意味着我们只是用一个问题换取另一个问题。与大规模饥荒相比，肥胖确实是一个更容易处理的问题。但这确实意味着我们的工作永远不会结束。同样，绿色革命确实在化肥径流污染物、合成肥料以及传统农业模式的取代方面产生了一些副作用。不过，鉴于拯救了十亿人的生命，这些代价
temporarily that worth accepting, but they don't have to be with us forever. We can now set as the next problem to be solved, a more sustainable method of feeding the world, less pollution, and less environmental degradation. less environmental degradation. We've been talking about why, for Stephen Pinker, our current era is the greatest time in all of human history to be alive. He says that the world as a whole has gotten better over the past several hundred years, we are more literate, more healthy, less hungry and less violent than ever before.
暂时是值得接受的，但它们不需要永远伴随着我们。我们现在可以将更具可持续性的养活世界的方法、更少的污染和更少环境退化，设定为下一个要解决的问题。更少的环境退化。我们一直在讨论为什么对史蒂芬·平克来说，我们当前这个时代是人类历史上生存的最好时期。他说，过去几百年里，世界整体上变得越来越好，与以往相比，我们受教育程度更高、更健康、更少挨饿、暴力也更少。
Thanks to institutions like the United Nations, slavery and human trafficking are largely banned if not yet eradicated. Stephen argues that the source of such progress can be traced to a change in thinking about 250 years ago, the era of the Enlightenment. It was a time in Europe when science, logic and reason replaced faith, dogma and folklore as a proper way to find the truth. Gut feelings and assumptions, like the idea that the Earth was at the center of the universe was scrutinized and discarded. We entered an era of health, scientific discoveries, and human flourishing. What's not to like, right?
多亏了联合国等机构，奴隶制和人口贩运在很大程度上已被禁止，即使尚未被彻底根除。史蒂芬认为，这种进步的根源可以追溯到大约 250 年前思想的一次变革，即启蒙运动时期。那是欧洲的一个时代，科学、逻辑和理性取代了信仰、教条和民间传说，成为寻找真理的正确途径。诸如“地球是宇宙中心”之类凭直觉和假设产生的想法受到了审视并被抛弃。我们进入了一个健康、科学发现和人类繁荣的时代。有什么不好呢，对吧？
But Stephen says these values hide an array of ideas that cut to the core of basic disagreements we find in America today. In fact, whether we realize it or not, he says that Westerners have been arguing over the legacy of the Enlightenment for the past 250 years, and the critiques come from both the left and the right. Well, from the right there is a kind of a longstanding counter-enlightenment current, that a secular worldview that there are forces of nature, that the brain is itself an evolutionary adaptation, goes against a traditional view in which morality
但史蒂芬表示，这些价值观背后隐藏着一系列观念，这些观念直指我们今天在美国发现的基本分歧的核心。事实上，无论我们是否意识到，他说西方人在过去 250 年里一直在争论启蒙运动的遗产，而批评声既来自左翼，也来自右翼。嗯，从右翼来看，有一种长期存在的反启蒙运动思潮，即世俗的世界观、存在自然规律、大脑本身是一种进化适应，这违背了传统的观点——在传统观点中，道德
is rooted in religion and the institutions of church in societal customs. And the idea that we're on our own, where we are our bodies and brains, it's up to us to figure out how to make our lives better, is really a different way of thinking of the human condition. More concretely, the fact that I argue that many of the improvements have come about through institutions that the contemporary American right to tests like government, like international institutions such as the United Nations, programs of social spending, environmental regulation. I admit that I myself was skeptical of a number of these things until I looked at the graphs and showed that a lot of them work, not perfectly, not all the time, but thanks to the Environmental Protection Agency
以及《清洁空气法》和《清洁水法》，空气和水确实变得更干净了。但我们并没有因此遭受经济萧条。我们变得更富有，我们开车行驶的里程更多，所以监管实际上起到了作用。右翼对人类机构产生反感，这些机构源自世俗的启蒙原则，而这些原则似乎一直在发挥作用。
and the Clean Air and Clean Water Act, the air really has gotten cleaner and the water. But we have not suffered a depression as a result. We've gotten richer, we drive more miles, so regulation actually worked. The right has a problem with the fact that human institutions derived from secular enlightenment principles seem to have been working.
还有《清洁空气法》和《清洁水法》，空气和水确实变得更干净了。但我们并没有因此遭受经济萧条。我们变得更富有了，我们行驶的里程更多了，所以监管确实发挥了作用。右翼对人类从世俗启蒙原则中衍生出的制度似乎一直在起作用这一事实感到难以接受。
The left has a problem with also the idea that there's anything worth saving in our institutions, particularly the market, that even though the failures of completely planned economies and communist systems are dramatically obvious to anyone who studies history. There's still a certain romanticism for socialism and hatred of markets, being another brainchild of the Enlightenment, including the idea that commerce is a pacifying force,
左翼也对我们的机构中有什么值得拯救的观点存在问题，特别是市场，尽管完全计划经济和共产主义系统的失败对于任何研究历史的人来说都是显而易见的。人们对社会主义仍然抱有一定的浪漫主义色彩，并且对市场怀有敌意，而市场也是启蒙运动的产物之一，包括商业是一种安抚力量的观点，
a civilizing force. If you're doing business with someone, you don't want to kill your customers, you don't want to kill your debtors. If it's cheaper to buy something and to steal it, you're going to be less tempted by plunder. These were ideas that were widely circulated during the enlightenment, but they often don't sit well with people on the left today. Partly because people both on the hard left and the hard libertarian right imagine that there's such a thing as unbridled unfettered capitalism, just free market without any social spending without any regulation, a kind of anarcho-capitalism.
一种文明的力量。如果你在和某人做生意，你不会想杀你的客户，你也不想杀你的债务人。如果买东西比偷东西更便宜，你就不会那么容易受到掠夺的诱惑。这些观点在启蒙运动期间广为流传，但它们往往不合当今左翼人士的心意。部分原因在于，极左翼和极自由意志主义右翼的人都认为存在着一种不受约束、不受限制的资本主义，即没有任何社会支出、没有任何监管的纯粹自由市场，一种无政府资本主义。
And that is often considered the ideal of the hard libertarian right and the boogie man of the hard socialist left. One of the things I discovered is it just doesn't exist, not even in the United States, which is one of the more libertarian countries, but every rich country, all of them, have extensive social safety nets and extensive networks of regulation, but both sides reject that reality. You offer an interesting psychological insight. I think this is from a financial writer who said that pessimists sound like they're trying to help you, optimists sound like they're trying to sell you something.
这通常被认为是极自由意志主义右翼的理想，也是极社会主义左翼的眼中钉。我发现的一件事是，它根本不存在，即使在美国也不是这样——美国是更倾向于自由意志主义的国家之一，但每一个富裕国家，无一例外，都有广泛的社会安全网和广泛的监管网络，但双方都拒绝承认这一现实。你提出了一个有趣的心理学见解。我想这是出自一位金融作家之说，他说悲观主义者听起来像是在试图帮你，而乐观主义者听起来像是在向你推销什么。
And he said this in myself. When someone comes to me with a positive story, I call it a feel good story, implying that it's somehow not real, it's just designed to make me feel better. When someone comes to me with a grim story, I don't call it a feel bad story, I just call it reality. Exactly. And I often have to remind people that I'm including fans. Oh, it's so nice that you're an optimist. To hear the optimist side of the story, it's really not about optimism.
他也这样说过我。当某人带着一个积极的故事来找我时，我称之为“感觉良好的故事”，暗示它在某种程度上不是真实的，它只是为了让我感觉更好而设计的。当某人带着一个严峻的故事来找我时，我不会称之为“感觉糟糕的故事”，我只称之为现实。没错。我经常不得不提醒人们，包括粉丝们。哦，你是个乐观主义者，真是太好了。听到故事积极的一面，这其实与乐观无关。
And you don't want optimism in the sense of a rose or your picture than what reality is. You want accuracy. And you want to know what has worked so that we can do more of it. You want to know what hasn't worked so that we can't repeat our blunders. You want to know where the problems are
你需要的不是那种盲目乐观，不是粉饰太平、脱离现实的乐观。你想要的是准确性。你想要了解什么方法行之有效，以便我们能做更多这样的事情。你想要了解什么方法行不通，这样我们就不会重复我们的失误。你想要知道问题在哪里，
so that you try to solve them. I don't know if that's optimism, but that isn't attitude that has paid off in the past, suggesting that there really isn't such a thing as fate. That we really can improve our lots. You know, I'm reminded from, as I was reading your book, of something that occurred to me many years ago, I was a journalist at the Washington Post
以便你尝试去解决它们。我不知道这是否算乐观，但这是一种过去曾带来回报的态度，表明世上其实并没有命运这回事。我们确实可以改善自己的生活。你知道，在读你的书时，我想起了多年前发生在我身上的一件事，那时我是《华盛顿邮报》的一名记者，
in the days after the 9-11 attacks. And you probably remember this, in the immediate aftermath of the attacks, people put the death toll at the World Trade Center and the Pentagon close to 50,000 lives. And over the following weeks and months the death toll started to fall, eventually settling just under 3,000 people. But in that intervening period when the death toll was initially presumed to be 50,000 and it started to fall, new rooms like the Washington Post had real difficulty telling people that the
在 9·11 袭击发生后的日子里。你可能还记得，在袭击发生后的直接余波中，人们将世界贸易中心和五角大楼的死亡人数估计接近 5,0000 人。而在接下来的几周和几个月里，死亡人数开始下降，最终稳定在不到 3,000 人。但在那个死亡人数最初被推定为 5,0000 并且开始下降的过渡时期，像《华盛顿邮报》这样的新闻机构在告诉人们
death toll was falling. And I think the reason it had real difficulty telling people that the death toll was falling. And I think the reason it was difficult was that people would have to write a story that used the word only. So you'd have to say it wasn't 50,000, it was only 45,000, or it wasn't 45,000, it was only 40,000. And to use the word only in a story about a tragedy like this felt disrespectful. And it got to the point where, you know, journalist covering the story knew that the death toll was falling, but you
死亡人数正在下降时遇到了真正的困难。我认为它在告诉人们死亡人数正在下降时遇到真正困难的原因是，人们必须写一篇包含“仅”这个词的文章。所以你得说，不是 5 万，而“仅仅”是 4.5 万，或者不是 4.5 万，而“仅仅”是 4 万。在一篇关于这样一场悲剧的文章中使用“仅”这个词，让人觉得很不尊重人。事情发展到这种程度，你知道的，报道这个故事的记者知道死亡人数在下降，但你
didn't actually read that story in the news because people felt like if they did it, they would be, you know, disrespectful to the people who had died and to the tragedy that had just unfolded. And I remember writing a story eventually about the psychology of why it was hard to write about good news. And I remember the national editor of the Washington Post coming up to me and saying, I'm really glad you wrote the story because writing a story about the psychology of why we couldn't write the story was the only way we could actually write the story about the falling death toll.
实际上在新闻里并没有读到那个报道，因为人们觉得如果他们这样做了，你知道的，就会对那些死去的人和刚刚发生悲剧表现得不尊重。我记得我最终写了一篇关于“为什么很难报道好消息”这一心理学的文章。我记得《华盛顿邮报》的国家新闻编辑走向我并对我说，我真的很高兴你写了这篇文章，因为写一篇关于“为什么我们无法写出这篇报道”的心理学文章，是我们实际上能够写出关于死亡人数下降报道的唯一方法。
That's fascinating. And indeed, you have put your finger on a force that that that that that militates against accuracy in reporting, which is that if you've got skin in the game, good news can be bad news and vice versa. And I have to be careful because another complication for this kind of message is I certainly don't want to be joining in the course of people who attack the mainstream media, MSM, because for all of the distortions that are built into the very nature of journalism, it is the
太迷人了。确实，你已经敏锐地指出了一个阻碍新闻报道准确性的力量，那就是如果你身在其中、利益攸关，好消息可能会变成坏消息，反之亦然。我必须小心，因为这类信息的另一个复杂之处在于，我当然不想加入那些攻击主流媒体（MSM）的人的行列，因为尽管新闻业的本质中存在着各种各样的扭曲，但
mainstream media who are far more likely to correct their own errors, to set up objectivity as a value in itself than a lot of the alternatives, the blogosphere and the Twitter sphere and political parties. So I'm mindful that pointing out some of the inherent biases in the very nature of journalism is not yet another reason to be cynical about the journalist who are working very hard to present the most accurate picture they can. Just that, but it is, in fact, to the credit of journalists that they themselves
主流媒体比博客圈、推特圈以及政党更有可能纠正自己的错误，将客观性视为一种价值本身。因此，我注意到，指出新闻业本质中固有的一些偏见，并不是对那些努力呈现最准确画面的记者们抱持冷嘲热讽态度的又一个理由。仅仅如此，但事实上，记者们自己能够
are mindful of the ways in which news can distort our understanding of the world. So I consider it to be a friendly message, an Amicus brief, so to speak. I'm wondering how an ongoing global pandemic changes your view of things. I mean, your book really, you're saying it's not sort of an optimistic view of the world,
意识到新闻可能会扭曲我们对世界的理解，这正是他们的功劳。所以我认为这是一个友好的信息，可以说是递交了一份“法庭之友简报”。我想知道，一场持续的全球大流行是如何改变你对事物的看法的。我的意思是，你的书确实在说，这并非某种对世界的乐观看法，
but it's certainly it's a positive view of saying, there's a lot that has changed for the better, pay attention to it, acknowledge it, be grateful to it. Can you still maintain that attitude in the face of a terrible global pandemic that is you know costing you know tens of thousands of lives and many many many billions of dollars and lost revenues and unemployment and suffering all around the world?
但它肯定是一种积极的看法，意思是：有很多事情已经发生了好的转变，要注意它，承认它，对它心存感激。面对一场可怕的全球大流行——它你知道的，正夺去成千上万人的生命，造成数以亿计的收入损失、失业以及世界各地的人们在受苦——你还能保持这种态度吗？
Documenting the facts of human progress is not the same as saying bad things can never happen again. Quite the contrary. Progress is always a somewhat sycophony in battle against the forces of nature that grind us down, including infectious disease. We are, it's just in the nature of life that natural selection is a competitive process. Our bodies are from the point of view of a germ, big yummy mounds of chocolate cake, they're for the eating. In fact, from a virus's point of view, our bodies are bakeries. They have all the machinery necessary to make more. And we are sitting ducks to disease organisms,
记录人类进步的事实，并不等于说坏事永远不会再次发生。恰恰相反。进步在某种程度上是一场与那些将我们磨灭的自然力量（包括传染病）进行的不屈不挠的战斗。从一个病菌的角度来看，我们的身体就是大块美味的巧克力蛋糕，它们是用来吃的，这就是自然选择是一个竞争过程的生命本质。事实上，从病毒的角度来看，我们的身体就是面包房。它们拥有制造更多病毒所需的所有机器。而我们对于致病微生物来说就是唾手可得的猎物，
all organisms are sitting ducks, even bacteria are infected by viruses. It's part of the nature of life, and it will always be a challenge. There will always be setbacks. Certainly we were left flatfooted, we were not sufficiently prepared, and one hopes that we treat this root shock of the COVID pandemic of 2020, the way earlier generations treated massive fires, they set up fire departments. And those preparedness in terms of sprinkler systems and alarms and exit doors and lighted signs and fire departments, even if they sat around idle most of the time, the potential was so catastrophic that it was worth maintaining that constant level of preparedness.
所有生物都是唾手可得的猎物，甚至连细菌也会被病毒感染。这是生命本质的一部分，而且它将永远是一个挑战。总会有挫折。当然，我们被打了个措手不及，我们没有做好充分的准备，人们希望我们对待 2020 年新冠大流行这种根源性冲击的方式，就像早期几代人对待大火一样，他们成立了消防部门。这种在喷淋系统、警报器、安全出口门、发光标志和消防部门方面的准备工作，即使它们大部分时间都闲置着，但由于潜在后果是如此灾难性的，因此保持这种持续的防范水平是值得的。
That's really what we ought to do with the threat of pandemics. They can always happen. We did not anticipate them. We, meaning most of the world. And there ought to be agitation and pressure to not let it get as far as it did in the future. Isn't it sort of psychologically interesting, Steve, that sort of giving people what journalists would call an honest account of the world, that the world is going to hell in a hand basket, which is what you feel like when you're reading the news every day, unintentionally produces feelings of despair. Whereas actually reminding people of the things that have changed in their life for the better gives people a sense of saying, if this has happened over the last
这确实是我们面对大流行威胁时应该做的事情。它们随时可能发生。我们没有预料到它们。我们，指的是世界大多数人。应该有呼声和压力，不要让它在未来发展到像这次这么严重的地步。史蒂夫，给人们提供记者们所说的那种诚实的对世界的描述——即世界正在不可救药地走向毁灭，这也是你每天读新闻时的感觉——这在心理上不是很奇妙吗，它无意中产生了绝望感。而实际上，提醒人们生活中发生的美好变化，会给人们带来这样一种感觉：如果过去
200 years, well, maybe even more can happen over the next 200. Indeed, and it shouldn't only be over the last 200 years, because a lot of these changes are changes over the last 30 or 40 years within the memories of older adults. So we're not just talking about the history books. We're not talking about accomplishments that only our great grandchildren will appreciate in retrospect.
200年里发生了这些，嗯，也许在接下来的200年里还会发生更多。确实如此，而且不应该仅仅局限于过去 200 年，因为其中许多变化是过去 30 或 40 年内、在年长成年人的记忆中发生的变化。所以我们谈论的不仅仅是历史书。我们谈论的不是只有我们的曾孙在回顾时才会欣赏的成就，
We are talking about changes that we can enjoy in our lifetimes and lifetimes of our children. Mm. Do you worry that the message of your book might produce complacency in the sense of saying someone says, well, the truth is we've actually solved 90% of the problem when it comes to things like famine. And we should spend more time patting ourselves on the back rather than looking
我们谈论的是我们可以在有生之年以及我们孩子的有生之年享受到的变化。嗯。你是否担心你书中的传达的信息会产生自满情绪，比如说有人说，事实是，当涉及到饥荒之类的事情时，我们实际上已经解决了 90% 的问题。我们应该把更多的时间花在自我祝贺上，而不是去寻求
to solve the other 10% of the problem. I haven't seen that. Looking at the people who are sometimes lumped with me as the new optimists, they're often the ones who are at the front lines of dealing with the problems that remain. These are the people like Bill Gates and other active philanthropists, economists determined to eliminate extreme poverty,
解决剩下的 10% 的问题。我没有看到这种情况。看看那些有时与我一起被归为“新乐观主义者”的人，他们往往是那些站在应对遗留问题最前线的人。这些人包括比尔·盖茨和其他积极的慈善家、决心消除极端贫困的经济学家、
to satisfy the sustainable development goals, dreamers and activists and optimists. They're the ones who are most aware of the progress that we have made. And it's often the people who falsely believe that things have gotten worse and worse, who tend to be the nihilists, the bomb throwers, the lovers of chaos, the cynics, the ones who just want to blow up the system. So yeah, I don't think that it's a problem. I have not seen
去实现可持续发展目标的梦想家、行动主义者和乐观主义者。他们才是最清楚我们所取得进步的人。而往往是那些错误地认为情况越来越糟的人，才倾向于成为虚无主义者、炸弹投掷者、混乱爱好者、愤世嫉俗者，那些只想炸毁体制的人。所以，是的，我不认为这是一个问题。我没有看到
anyone say, well, our work has done, everyone's rich, everyone's happy, everyone's healthy. Psychologist Stephen Pinker is the author of Enlightenment Now, the Case for Reason, Science, Humanism, and Progress. Steve, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure and an honor. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy,
任何人说，我们的工作完成了，每个人都很富有，每个人都很快乐，每个人都很健康。心理学家史蒂芬·平克是《当下的启蒙：为理性、科学、人文主义和进步辩护》一书的作者。史蒂夫，谢谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。这是一种荣幸，也是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。Midrall Media 是我们的独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、
Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to Thomas Liu, voiceovers by Deba Motasham, Jared Gare and Christina Calla. Our unsung heroes this week are two men of science, doctors Amos Willis and Barry Mandel. A few weeks ago, I found myself several hours away from my home in Washington, DC. I was traveling in North Carolina
劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行编辑。本周要特别感谢托马斯·刘，配音由德巴·莫塔沙姆、贾里德·加雷和克里斯蒂娜·卡拉提供。我们本周的无名英雄是两位科学工作者，阿莫斯·威利斯医生和巴里·曼德尔医生。几周前，我发现自己身处距离华盛顿特区家园几个小时车程的地方。我在北卡罗来纳州旅行时
when I started to experience severe vision problems. It turned out I was having a retinal detachment, a serious condition that can cause blindness if left untreated. Amos and Barry went out of their way to help me deal with the emergency. They opened their practices for me after hours, they got me into emergency surgery at Virginia Beach General Hospital. They saved my right eye. I'm reading these words today because they acted with great speed, kindness and skill. I'm so grateful to them. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. Find more information
开始出现严重的视力问题。事实证明我患了视网膜脱离，这是一种如果不及时治疗会导致失明的严重疾病。阿莫斯和巴里不遗余力地帮我处理这个紧急情况。他们在非营业时间为我开门接诊，他们把我送进弗吉尼亚海滩总医院进行紧急手术。他们拯救了我的右眼。我今天读这些话是因为他们行动迅速、心地善良、医术高超。我非常感激他们。想了解更多《隐秘大脑》的内容，你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们。了解关于我们的更多信息
about us at hiddenbrain.org. If you like this episode and like our show, please tell your friends. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please show them. Next week on the show, we continue our series on counterintuitive ideas for understanding the state of the world in 2020. We look at moral convictions and how viewing politics through a prism of right and wrong shapes our ability to achieve our goals. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedanta. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 hiddenbrain.org。如果你喜欢这一集并喜欢我们的节目，请告诉你的朋友。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请教教他们。下周的节目中，我们将继续我们的系列节目，探讨用于理解 2020 年世界状态的反直觉观点。我们将审视道德信念，以及通过对错棱镜来审视政治如何塑造我们实现目标的能力。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。